PROFESSOR: All right.
The end of this lecture
generated so much excitement
that we've continued on into the
start of the next segment.
So I think we'd better begin.
What I told you, as several
people were clever enough to
observe, that the number of
planes between the origin and
intercept plane is equal to A
times B times C, where the
intercept is A T1 out plus
B T2 out equals C T3 out.
That is true only if the
numbers A, B, and C are
mutually prime.
If it's something like 4,
2, 1, you won't get
that number of planes.
You'll get a submultiple.
And the reason for that is that
some of the planes, when
you generate them by these three
different translations
in different directions, some
of them are mapped on top of
existing planes.
And I'm not going to attempt to
prove this, but let me just
tell you the result, that if
A and B contain some common
factor, p, and B and C contain
some common factor, q, and in
the worst possible case, A and C
contains some common factor,
r, then the number of intervals
is equal to A times
B times C divided by
p times q times r.
And probably the best way to
show that is let you show, on
a problem set in the very near
future, to actually map out
the planes in the
two-dimensional situation, for
a and b that are mutually prime,
and then do the same
thing for a and b that contain
some common factor.
So this is the so-called
Miller indices, the
Miller-Bravais indices, and
everybody hears about them,
but it is not at all clear why
one takes this very indirect
and non-intuitive way
of defining the
orientation of a plane.
And the reason for this,
ultimately, is that in x-ray
diffraction, you want to
integrate up the scattering of
all atoms in a crystal.
So you want to integrate over
a plane that contains the
atoms, and this locus has a
convenient form only if you
choose these indices to find the
orientation of the plane.
And what comes out of this, as
I said to a couple of people
during intermission, is that the
amplitude of the scattered
wave has some summation
over all of the atoms.
And in that phase of that ray,
that is e to the plus 2 pi i,
hx plus ky plus lz.
Very, very simple form.
And it has that form only
because the locus, the way
this plane is defined was done
very, very carefully.
So it's something beyond just
simple geometry that forms a
reason for it.
Let me say a couple more things
in general about the
Miller-Bravais indices.
They are very, very intuitive,
counter-intuitive.
Let's suppose that this is a,
and this is b, and this is c.
And I put down here, again, the
equations of the entire
set of planes in the stack.
And let's look at the first
planes and ask what the
intercepts are.
The intercepts on x, y, and z
are going to be 1 over h on x,
1 over k on y, and
1 over l times z.
So the first plane from the
origin is going to be 1 over h
of the a translation, 1 over k
of the b translation, and 1
over l of the c translation.
So this gives us one way
of determining, given a
particular rational plane, show
it relative to the three
translations.
From the first plane from the
origin, h is going to be 1
over the intercept on T1.
I'll call it a, which is
what we usually do.
k is going to be 1 over the
intercept on b, and l is going
to be 1 over the intercept
on c for the first
plane from the origin.
So if you have a drawing of the
set of planes relative to
the translation, such as the
one that I obliterated from
just a moment ago, reciprocals
of the intercepts of the first
plane from the origin give you
h, k, and l very easily.
The thing that is
counter-intuitive is that, if
you look out of context at the
three indices, h, k, and l,
you have the feeling that as l
gets larger, the intercept of
the plane on c should gradually
creep up from here,
to here, to here, and so
on, as l gets larger.
Actually, the reverse is true.
As l increases, the intercept on
c gets smaller and smaller
and smaller and smaller, until
finally, when l is infinity,
the intercept is 0.
So it's counter-intuitive.
The intercept on the axis gets
larger as the Miller index
gets larger.
Let me give you a proprietary
Uncle Bernie's secret method
for determining Miller indices
without stress and strain.
This works every time.
Find the intercepts
of any plane.
And we know from these
equations what those
are going to be.
For the nth plane, the
intercepts are going to be n
over h, n over k on b,
and n over l on c.
Take the reciprocals.
And the reciprocals are going
to be h over n, k over
n, and l over n.
And then find whatever integer,
n, you must multiply
those reciprocals by in order
to convert them to mutually
prime intercepts, and you've
got the Miller indices in a
no-brainer, automatic fashion.
Another bit of jargon.
We will also use the basis
vectors to define locations
and to define directions
in a lattice.
To distinguish three integers
that indicate a plane, and you
all know this from previous
experience, the parentheses
says plane, an individual
plane.
There are other times when you
would like to use the indices
of one representative plane to
indicate the entire set of
planes that are related by the
symmetry of the crystal.
So let me give one
specific example.
Suppose we had a cubic crystal,
where these are the
three translations that form
the edge of the unit cell.
And let's say that this is a1,
this is a2, and this is a3.
I'm using a1, a2, and
a3, not a, b, and c.
But let's not go there.
OK, these are lattice points.
And if I look at this plane
that's perpendicular to a1 and
cuts it at one lattice
point, l, this would
be the 1, 0, 0 plane.
And I would indicate that that
is an individual plane that
we're talking about.
But if this crystal is cubic,
all six faces of the set, 1,
0, 0; 0, 1, 0; 0, 0, 1; and then
the plane that's in the
opposite direction, minus
1, 0, 0; 0, minus 1, 0;
and 0, 0, minus 1.
These six planes define the
surfaces of the cube.
So there are times, since these
are equivalent to planes
and will have the same
properties, the same hardness,
the same [? edge ?] bits and
everything else, there are
times when we may want to
refer to the entire
symmetrical set.
And we do that.
We call that set a form.
It is a symmetry-related set.
And you can pick any
one you like.
Generally, you pick one with
simple indices, like the one
that is perpendicular to
the translation a.
And then you indicate
by braces, which is
the symbol for set.
This means the set 1, 0, 0, and
that would correspond to
all six of these faces.
The number, if you do this in
reverse, and I'm going to give
you the indices, what are
the separate faces?
That depends on the symmetry.
So to give you an example, if
I have a unit cell that has
three orthogonal translations,
and this is a, and this is b,
and this is c, so that there
is no cubic symmetry to it.
This face, which would be 1,
0, 0, and the one that cuts
the axes at minus a, minus 1, 0
0, those are going to be the
only faces with a single 1 and
a pair of 0's which are
equivalent by symmetry.
So in this case, for this brick
shaped unit cell, 1, 0,
0 would mean this pair of two
faces, rather than six.
So to go from a representative
face to the set of planes, you
have to know the symmetry.
If you can write the planes on
the basis of symmetry, take
one representative and
let that be the form.
So it leads one to observe
that crystals undergoing
plastic deformation
have bad form.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Is that different
from when you
talk about a direction?
PROFESSOR: Yes, yes.
You will see in just a moment
that we use the same system of
three integers, but in order to
distinguish which one he's
talking about when one's
thinking about integers with a
different set of numbers.
Again, if we use the lattice as
the basis of a coordinate
system, another thing we might
want to specify is the
orientation of a rational
direction.
And let me go to a
two-dimensional case.
Assume that c goes
straight up.
Directions of easy plastic
deformation will very often
involve integral number
of translations.
For example, this direction here
is obtained by going one
translation in the a
direction plus one
translation in the b direction.
So we could use the pair of
integers 1, 1, and if we are
normal to see we'd use a 0
for the third integer.
But how are we going to tell
whether we're talking about a
direction or a plane?
And the way one does that is
to use square braces to
indicate one particular
direction.
You may want to also indicate
the location of a particular
atom within the unit cell.
In order to do that, one could
really use the location of a
vector, the components of a
vector, xa plus yb plus zc,
the vector from the origin to
that atom as coefficients
which correspond to
the atom location.
So if that is the case,
the numbers
are usually not integers.
And one simply uses the
three integers in
an unadorned fashion.
So the lattice translations
give you the basis of a
coordinate system, and we use
those to specify features,
rational or not, of planes and
directions and coordinates.
OK, any questions here?
OK, we are next going to take
the first small step in a
process of synthesis.
We have found that there are,
in two dimensions, five
distinct kinds of lattices.
The oblique, the rectangular,
the centric rectangular, the
square, and the hexagonal.
Five kinds of lattices.
We've shown, to this point, that
each of these lattices
can accommodate a certain
rotational symmetry.
1 or 2 here.
m and m for the rectangular
and centric rectangular.
4, the fourfold axis
for a square.
3 or 6 for the hexagonal
lattice.
So what I would like to do next,
after we make a brief
direct diversion, is to combine
with each of these
nets one of the two symmetries
which can be
accommodated in that net.
And what we will have determined
then are the
patterns' lattice and symmetry,
which can exist in
two dimensions.
The sort of things we look at
actually, like the pattern of
square tiles on the floor, or
the two-dimensional pattern
that is on a fabric design.
So we'll derive those
exhaustively.
The thing that results is
something that is called a
plane group.
And I'm going to take this
through in detail because
there are not that many
combinations that can be made.
And the number is enough
to count on
your fingers and toes.
You've got to use both, so
they're a fair number, but not
a staggering number.
If we were to do this exercise
in three dimensions, there
would be 230 distinct
combinations.
And that's too much for
anybody to go through.
I know of very few people who
work professionally in this
area who've actually sat down
and derived every single one.
If you know the principles of
the derivation and know how
you could go about doing it if
you were forced to, that's
sufficient.
The results are tabulated in
an admirable compilation.
We mentioned that at
the beginning.
This is the International
Tables for X-ray
Crystallography, Volume 1.
So what we should end up with is
a way for you to go to this
reference data and know
how to interpret it
and make use of it.
But this is a nice microcosm.
There are not many plane
groups, and to do this
exhaustively, will let us see
the sort of reasoning that
goes into it.
I have to tell you that this
is not in Buerger's book.
We're going to do
two-dimensional
crystallography first,
and then extend
it in a third direction.
In fact, I know of no
book that does this.
And so you're going to get a
unique, handwritten document
by none other than yours truly
that will do this in detail
every step of the way.
And I don't know of any other
place where this is done.
Now, what is the origin
of this name?
Plane, well, these
are symmetries
confined to a plane.
And then there's this mysterious
term, group.
And the corresponding thing
in 3D is something
called a space group.
This is a language derived from
a branch of mathematics
that is called group theory, and
it is exactly the language
that describes things
that we've mentioned
conversationally, such as if you
take two transformations
and perform them in succession,
they're going to
give you a third that
has to be present.
If you've got two present,
there must be a third.
We talk about symmetries
being self consistent.
If you have a rotation operation
that is not an
integral submultiple of 2 pi,
it's not going to be self
consistent because you go
around, and around, and
around, and you will never
come exactly full circle.
So group theory is a branch of
mathematics that deals with
concepts of this sort.
So it's not very hard to
develop, and it gives its
ideas to the notation that is
used in crystallography.
So let me say a few words
about group theory.
What is a group?
A group is a set of elements--
And what are elements?
Elements are things--
For which a law of combination
is defined.
And the nature of the elements
can be very,
very different things.
They could be numbers.
They could be complex numbers,
and the law of combination
here might be multiplication.
They could be matrices, for
which the law of combination
is defined as matrix
multiplication.
Or they could be pots of
different color paint, for
which the law of combination is
defined as mixing the two
colors 50-50.
I don't know any practical
application of that sort of
group, but nevertheless, it
follows the definition, a set
of things for which a law of
combination is defined.
And in addition, which satisfies
three so-called
group postulates.
And the group postulates are
the combination of any two
elements is also a member
of the group.
The second group postulate
is that the identity--
I'm going to call it
just identity--
and let me define, identity
is doing nothing--
Is also a member of the group.
And if we define the identity
operation as I, this means
that for every element, I
followed by a or a followed by
I, is the same as a by itself.
If the law of multiplication
were just arithmetic
multiplication, then number
1 would be the identity
operation because 1 times any
number gives you the number.
Any number times 1 gives you
the same number back again.
And the third postulate is that,
for every element, an
inverse exists--
let's call the elements
a and a minus 1--
such that a followed by a
minus 1 is equal to the
identity operation, and the
inverse element followed by
the original element, a, is also
the identity operation.
So if the law of combination
were defined as
multiplication, you would have
to find, for every number,
another number, which multiplied
by it, gives you
the number 1.
OK, let me now illustrate with
a couple of simple examples.
Let's consider the set of
numbers 1, n minus 1.
The number of elements in the
group is said to be the rank
of the group, or some people
like to use the term order.
And I don't like that term
because second order or fourth
order is a term applied to
quantities which are not
terribly important.
So we expand this except for
higher order terms, which are
negligible.
And I don't like that
connotation.
So I will not use order,
although it's sometimes used
to talk about the
rank of a group.
The rank or order of the group
is simply the number of
elements contained in a set.
So let's show that the numbers
1 and minus 1 constitute a
group of rank two.
Is the combination of any
pair of elements also a
member of the group?
Well, to do this, it's
convenient to set up an array
called the group multiplication
table.
And what you do is you simply
put the elements of the group
along a row.
And in this case, it's
1 and minus 1.
And then you put the same
elements along a column, and
then you combine them.
1 times 1 is 1.
Minus 1 times 1 is minus 1.
1 times minus 1 is minus 1.
Minus 1 times minus
1 is plus 1.
Sometimes, as I'm giving this
part of the lecture, somebody
passes down the hallway, and
they hear 1 times 1 is 1.
1 times minus 1--
and they go in reverse to see
what in the world could be
going on in this high-powered
mathematical lecture.
That's why I close the door.
OK, so any combination
of elements is also a
member of the group.
Is the identity operation
present?
Yes because minus 1 times plus
1 or plus 1 times minus 1
gives you the same element
back again.
So for every element in the
group, the combination of any
two elements is present.
For each operation, we've shown
that an inverse exists
and for every element there's an
identity operation, and the
inverse exists.
So the pair of numbers, not
terribly exciting, 1 and minus
1 where the law of combination
is defined is a
group of rank 2.
I'll give you another example.
I won't bother to carry out all
the terms, but the numbers
1, minus 1, i, and minus i,
where i is equal to the square
root of minus 1, and where the
law of combination is defined
as multiplication, constitute
a group of rank 4.
With this simple introduction,
I think one can see that
symmetry transformations can be
regarded as operations that
are elements in a group.
And let me give you
a simple example.
Let's look at a combination.
We still haven't considered the
mind-boggling possibility
of having more than one symmetry
element present in a
space at the same time.
But let's suppose we have two
mirror planes that are
completely orthogonal, and see
what sort of pattern they
would generate.
Here's a first motif.
If I call this mirror plane m1,
and this mirror plane m2.
m1 is going to take this
object and reflect
it across to here.
m2 will take this object and
reflect it down to here.
Take this one, and reflect
it down to here.
And now I know how this is
related to this, how this is
related to this, how this
is related to this.
But this one and this one are
exactly the same thing.
And those two objects are not
related by reflection.
If this is a right-handed one,
this is a left-handed one,
this is a left-handed one, and
this is a right-handed one.
So if something relates these
two, it has to be something
that does not produce
an enantiomorph.
The only thing that's possible
then would be translation.
And these two guys are not
parallel to one another.
You can't get this one
by just sliding
this parallel to itself.
The only thing that's
left is rotation.
And, lo and behold, we can get
from this one to this one by a
180-degree rotation.
And we can get from this
one to this one by
a 180-degree rotation.
So here's an example of a way
in which we've combined
without showing why this is
possible, or how I got there.
Here's a combination of symmetry
elements that gives
us a possible arrangement
of objects in space.
It's going to be convenient to
have a notation to indicate
such combinations.
And we call them Harry, George,
and Sam, or some
popular, affectionate name.
Or call them number 1,
number 2, number 3.
But a nice notation is going to
be a descriptive one which
tells you what you have.
And what is done in
crystallography is to indicate
these possible combinations
by a running list of the
different kinds of symmetry
elements that are present.
And here, we've got a twofold
axis, for which the symbol is
2, and two mirror planes that
are different and function in
different ways in the pattern.
So this combination
is called 2mm.
OK, that's getting ahead
of our story.
But what I wanted to do now is
to show you that this set of
symmetry elements contains
four operations that
constitute a group.
There's the operation
of a one-fold axis.
That's the identity operation.
There is a reflection
across the first
type of mirror plane.
And notice, now, the utility
of having a symbol that
indicates a specific
operation rather
than a symmetry element.
There's a second reflection
operation, sigma 2, and there
is a rotation operation through
a 180 degrees, A pi.
So I'd like to show that these
four operations constitute a
group of rank 4.
So how do we show this?
We first set up the group
multiplication table.
And then we simply
combine these
four operations pairwise.
Put the same 1, sigma 1,
sigma 2, and A pi down
this side of the array.
Doing nothing, doing nothing, is
the same as a one-fold axis
doing nothing.
Doing a reflection sigma 1
followed by doing nothing
gives you sigma 1 back again.
Doing a reflection sigma 2
followed by doing nothing
gives you sigma 2 back again.
And similarly, rotating
A pi followed by doing
nothing is the same.
If I go along the columns,
doing nothing followed by
sigma 1 is sigma 1.
Sigma 1 and 1 combined
is sigma 2.
A pi combined with
sigma 1 is A pi.
So far so good, but
not surprising.
Doing sigma 1 and following it
by sigma 1 is reflecting left
to right across mirror plane 1,
and then reflecting right
back again.
So that is going to be a
one-fold axis doing nothing.
Doing sigma 1 following up by
sigma 2 would reflect across,
and then follow up by reflection
in the second
mirror plane.
I get from the first one
to the final one by
the rotation A pi.
So this is A pi.
And if I do the first
reflection, sigma 1, and
follow that by A pi, that gets
me from number 1 to number 2
to number 3.
And I get from number 1 to
number 3 directly by the
reflection operation, sigma 2.
OK, you notice what's
happening?
I get the same four elements
back again in
every column or row.
Sigma 1, 1, A pi, sigma 2.
And if I rattle these off
quickly, this as A pi.
This is identity, and
this is sigma 1.
And this will be sigma 2.
This will be sigma 1.
And this will be the
identity operation.
So the first group postulate
is satisfied.
These four elements combined
pairwise always give you
nothing but one of these
elements back.
An identity operation is present
because the one-fold
rotation axis is the same as
leaving the thing alone.
And we've seen that for every
operation, an inverse exists
because 1 occurs once in
each row and column.
So sigma 2 is its own inverse,
and for sigma 1, sigma 1 is
its own inverse.
For A pi, A pi is
So an inverse exists.
So we've got a group.
And this is another way of
saying, in general terms, if
we put two mirror planes and a
twofold axis together in this
specific fashion, these
operations, when they go to
work on an initial motif,
reproduce a finite set of
objects and not a clutter that
just fills space and never
closes upon itself.
Yes, sir?
AUDIENCE: I see why you have
sigma 1, sigma 2, A pi in that
group, but why do you have the
1, which is a conversion?
PROFESSOR: OK.
If I didn't put it in-- no,
that's the identity operation.
This is a one-fold axis.
Just this 2 was a
twofold axis.
So one-fold axis is a nice
symbol for identity because it
doesn't do anything.
It picks something up and
puts it right back down
where it came from.
OK.
Yeah.
That's deceptive because 1,
when we're talking about
multiplication of numbers,
also functions as
the identity operation.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: If all these
symmetries are commutative,
[? that is, ?]
if they all commute, do you
really [INAUDIBLE] bottom
diagonal [INAUDIBLE]?
PROFESSOR: In general, yes.
AUDIENCE: Generally?
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
Actually, this is a special
group because if I have two
elements, a, and take b and
follow it by a, that is the
same result as a
followed by b.
And a group that has
this character
is said to be abelian.
There's a standing rotten joke
in mathematics that asks
rhetorically, what is
purple and commutes?
The answer is an
abelian grape.
I don't think it's terribly
funny either, but if you had a
gaggle of mathematicians here,
they would chortle and double
over in laughter.
Ha, ha, ha, abelian grape.
Well, I don't feel badly.
You react about the same
way to some of my
funny things, too.
But you get used to that
sort of thing.
All right.
The feeling I want to leave you
with at this point is the
idea that group theory and
some of its concepts are
exactly what we're meaning when
we grope for a definition
of the fact that a certain
collection of symmetry
operation should be finite.
That is to say, it's finite.
The operations combined on
each other have to give a
finite number, must constitute
a group.
And the main reason for being
familiar with this is that
group theory forms the basis of
a lot of the words that are
used to describe the
combinations of symmetry elements.
For example, what we have
derived here, the symmetry
that's called 2mm, is something
that's called a
point group.
Point because there is at
least one point in space
that's left unchanged, and
that's this point of
intersection of all three
symmetry elements.
And it's called a group
because the individual
operations of these symmetry
elements, when combined
according to group theory,
can be shown to
constitute a group.
The patterns that we get when we
add symmetry elements to a
lattice are groups in the
sense, if you regard the
pattern as extending infinitely
in all directions,
that the combination of any
two elements gives you
something that's also
in the group.
But the number of elements
is infinite.
For example, in the lattice,
here's T1.
Here's T2.
Every other lattice point
can be described as some
combination of T1
followed by T2.
But the numbers in
front of those
translations can be infinite.
If we put a symmetry element
in this lattice, like a
twofold axis, for example, the
translations reproduce this
twofold axis to an infinite
number of locations.
But yet, all of the group
postulates are satisfied.
The number of elements in the
group does, however, not have
to be finite.
So that is another distinction
that's worth making, that
there are infinite groups and
there are finite groups.
And the number of elements
can be infinite.
Collection of symmetry elements
that leave one point
in space unmoved is called
a point group.
If we do something like this,
put a twofold axis in
combination with a pair of
translations, that is an
infinite set of operations that
acts on all of space.
This is something that's
called a space group.
Another designation,
distinction, that's sometimes
useful to make are
crystallographic point groups,
such as this one, 2mm, as
opposed to combinations of
symmetry elements, which are
perfectly lovely and which are
valid groups, such as a
combination of rotations of 2
pi over 5, or a combination
of a fivefold axis
with a mirror plane.
Perfectly lovely symbols,
constitute groups, but these
are non-crystallographic
These would be
non-crystallographic point groups.
Satisfy all the requirements of
the group, but if it's to
be in a crystal, the fivefold
axis must be combined with
translation, and that's
impossible.
So you can have
non-crystallographic point groups.
There are no
non-crystallographic space
groups because they are, by
definition, something that
involve translation yet
constitute groups.
All right.
Set the stage for next time, so
you all come back excited.
We have shown that there are a
limited number of symmetry
elements that are possible in
a lattice, rotation 1, 2, 3,
4, and 6 in a mirror plane.
And these are now examples
of what we would call
crystallographic point groups.
These would be the sort of
symmetry elements that are
candidates for two-dimensional
patterns.
But are these the only
symmetries that can be added
to lattices?
Could we not combine a mirror
plane with a twofold axis?
The answer I say to
that is, sure.
You bet you can.
You just did it for us.
But could you combine a mirror
plane with a threefold axis, a
mirror plane with a fourfold
axis, a mirror plane with a
sixfold axis?
The answer to all of those
questions are yes.
So there are going to be spaces
here, where there will
be additional groups.
And when we're done, we will
have the two-dimensional
crystallographic point groups.
But now I have to be able
to complete something.
If I take A pi and combine it
with a mirror operation sigma
1, what do I get?
If I take A 2 pi over 3, a
threefold rotation, combine
that with a mirror plane
that passes through
it, what do I get?
Again, a characteristic of
symmetry theory is that
whenever I take a motif and
repeat it by operation number
1 to get a second motif, and
then I repeat that by
operation number
2, I have three
things that are identical.
And there must be some way,
some operation, that
automatically arises that
tells me how number 1 is
related to number 2.
Number 1 is related
to number 3.
Tied in with group theory, this
says that if you combine
operation 1 in a space, if
it's to be a group, if
operation number 2 is present,
you must combine those two
steps, and whatever pops up must
be a member of the set of
operations that are present.
So we're going to have to come
up with something that I call
combination theorems.
And this is simply expressing
the result of a combination of
two elements in a group
multiplication table.
It goes with a caveat.
If you're so excited about this
stuff, you're going to
run home and start reading
Buerger's book as
soon as you get there.
You can regard these symmetry
transformations as operators.
And you're familiar with other
sorts of operators like d by
dx, d by dy.
And when you apply them in
succession, you actually write
it as a product.
d by dy followed by d by dx you
write as d squared dxdy.
Or you write it as d squared
dx squared when you
differentiate twice.
You don't mean you take the
differential of the function
with respect to x and
then square it.
You mean you do this
operation twice.
So these are all operators.
And what we usually understand
is that if you do d by dy
first and then follow that with
d by dx, the sequence of
operation goes from
right to left.
And I think that will come right
quite naturally to you.
You do that with differentials
and other sort of operators.
That is what we'll do.
Not Martin Buerger.
A very strong-minded person,
and he did what
he thought was sensible.
And he said we read things
from left to right.
We read everything from
left to right.
So I will be damned if I'm going
to write d by dx, d by
dy to be a sequence of
operations that goes from
right to left.
So all throughout Buerger's
book-- and it's easy to get
adjusted to, if he writes A dot
B, he means B followed by
A. Whereas normally, in the
calculus of operations, we
will use, as the rest of the
world does, this is A followed
by B. Trivial point, but one
that can throw you for a loop
the first time you see
it in Buerger's book
if you follow it.
Distinction does not matter
if the group is abelian.
So that the order of operations
doesn't make any
difference.
OK, that's enough for one day.
Beginning next time, know we
will start to begin this
process of synthesis.
And the first thing we'll ask
is, how do you combine a
rotation operation with a
reflection operation?
See you next week.